I've always been a fan of Superman so
just alone having the opportunity to to
literally wear his boots for a number of
movies I hope I hope that I get to play
more of Superman in years to come
my life has changed dramatically because
of it. It has given me plenty of
opportunity for roles and yeah it's been
one of those characters which changed
the entire course of my career and I'm
incredibly grateful for it and it's also
taught me a lot about myself the nature
of the character is so good he's so good
the character and he's so kind and
when you start to compare yourself
to him because you're playing him it...
You start to really look inwards and you
say am I a good person can I be a
good enough person to play Superman and
if you ever find it a whisper
in there which is like hmm hold on a
second maybe not then you adjust it and
and you make sure you are a better
person and I think that's all we can do
in life when as we grow and we
gain experiences is not beat ourselves
for the mistakes we make but to to
endeavour to be better people
as those mistakes happen.
Welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is going to be
my new Justice League Snyder cut in
Henry Cavill Superman video there's a
nice clip of him talking about the
Superman character his future as
Superman and his hope that he'll
continue to play Superman for many many
years to come beyond the contract that
he's getting ready to sign right now he
went on in this interview talking a
little bit about what's going on with
the Snyder cut what to expect as well as
what's going on with his time as
Superman in the upcoming movies so we'll
break it all down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos will do a new Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what you want
them to do with the new Superman Man of
Steel movie the funny thing about this
clip with Henry Cavill talking about the
Snyder cut is it is actually Patrick
Stewart who asked him to explain the
Justice League Snyder cut to him Henry
please explain to me what is this Snyder
cut you're talking about
it's part of an interview series that
variety is doing where actors interview
each other and sometimes they actually
have really cool clips this just happens
to be one of them and relevant because
there's so much Justice League Snider
cut stuff happening the past couple of
weeks
he didn't give away any big spoilers or
anything like that but that's him just
trying to not give anything away you
have to remember that henry cavill was
there for all the scenes that they film
was Superman so he knows the footage
that's going in the Schneider cut he
just can't talk about it really good
example is this picture Zack Snyder
posted from before they formally made
the announcement that they were doing
the Snyder cut he posted this saying
that it was all the reels of footage
that he filmed of the movie before he
was forced to leave the project not
including all the separate fully
computer-generated scenes that are going to
go back in the movie that they have
stored on hard drives really good
example of some major changes would be
like the big final battle scene a lot of
that would be fully special-effects just
because there's so much stuff going on
they changed a lot of the ending for the
theatrical cut I've already talked about
that a little bit what they wound up
doing and you kind of saw this play out
through the final couple of trailers
they released for it is that Zack Snyder
had already started working on some of
the big visual effects scenes the most
difficult complex ones and they would
repurpose that footage for the
theatrical cut like all these scenes
here at the end where all the skies are
red as opposed to the trailer footage
where it's a completely different color
this is what it looked like in Zack
Snyder's original version and what it'll
look like in the official Snyder cut
Zack Snyder actually said some funny
stuff about the theatrical cut of
Justice League 1 he said that he refuses
to watch it but he said that based on
what he knows about the theatrical cut
he says people have only seen about 25%
of the original footage that he shot in
it the Snyder cut is supposed to be over
four hours long that means that there's
over three and a half hours of
never-before-seen Justice League footage
that we're going to see next year
HBO max also clarified that the release
date is going to be sometime early to
spring next year so I'm assuming
sometime around April or May but I think
we were expecting that anyway because
they made the announcement towards the
end of May 3 and a half hours though is
enough for two whole movies of
never-before-seen Justice League footage
some of the stuff we've seen though in
the clips and early trailers that they
released in the behind the scenes videos
I've already done a couple videos on the
major storylines and deleted scenes that
we know about and after that the
Kolka came out there were some of the
deleted scenes that started floating
around the internet that you probably
seen the way they're releasing the
Schneider cut though makes it sound like
Zack Snyder intends on using almost
every last speck of footage that he
filmed in any big visual effect scenes
that were completely CG that they
started on but never got to finish so
when Henry Cavill is explaining the
Snyder cut to Patrick Stewart he just
talks about how he feels like it's
important for fans to be able to see the
directors original vision as it was
intended as for Henry Cavill saying that
he hopes to continue playing Superman
for many many years to come it sounds
like he's going for the Hugh Jackman
approach to the Superman character Hugh
Jackman played Wolverine for almost 20
years another good example is Robert
Downey jr. playing the Iron Man
character he played it for over 10 years
but he isn't approaching anything close
to Hugh Jackman yet even though we all
expect Robert Downey jr. to come back at
some point for a cameo scene way way
down the line right now what the raft
deadlines and variety of reporting is
that he's signing a contract to come
back for around three new crossover
movies instead of doing a Superman solo
movie like Man of Steel to the movies
that were reported that he's in talks
for are the flash flashpoint movie which
we just found out Michael Keaton is
coming back for is the 1989 Tim Burton
Batman he's a multiverse Batman not from
the same universe as the ben affleck
batman from Justice League that's how
they're explaining it the spider-man
into the spider-verse approach to the
Batman character in the DC EU movies in
fun coincidence too Michael Keaton is
also in the process of working out a
similar multi movie crossover deal just
like Henry Cavill's new Superman contract
where Michael Keaton would appear in
multiple upcoming new DC movies as his
older version of Batman I just did a
couple videos about Michael Keaton's
Batman coming back and how that's going to
work and what we know so far and the
other movies that he would cross over
into so I'll links for that at the end
of this video and in the description
because I think we all expected Henry
Cavill to come back because he's been
Superman so recently but getting Keaton
to come back that is a deep cut the
flash movie producers also confronted
the cyborg would make an appearance in
the movie but we know less about what
he's doing other than part of the movie
would take place around STAR Labs
because that's where cyborg hails from
the next big Superman crossover movie
would be the Black Adam movie with the
rock which
is filming later this year that's
supposed to be more but just a society
movie so if Henry Cavill shows up during
that it might just be a smaller cameo
scene or a fight scene with Black Adam
because why would you put Henry Cavill
Superman looking like this all swole in
a movie with the rock looking like this
and hype it up if you weren't planning
on letting them throw down then there's
Shazam to his cameo scene and that would
probably just be a larger version of the
Shazam Superman scene with Henry calvo's
face appearing in him actually getting
some lines giving some advice to the
Shazam Lee they did say that some of the
Henry Cavill appearances in future DC
movies would be really small and some of
them would be bigger then there's
Aquaman 2 we don't know much about the
plot of that movie other than Black
Manta is a much bigger villain than he
was in the first movie if they put Henry
Cavill in that movie it also might be a
shorter a cameo scene just because most
of that movie would be set underwater
and as cool as it would be to see
Superman visit Atlantis it just feels
weird to have him in an Aquaman movie
there's a reason why you don't see them
teaming up a ton outside a big Justice
League crossover stories in the comics
then there's Wonder Woman 3 which patty
Jenkins revealed is going to be set
during present day but because that
movie probably isn't going to get made for
three to four more years it's so far off
I think most of the upcoming Superman
crossovers are supposed to happen in the
next two to three years but then if
you've forgotten about it there is the
full-blown Darkseid New Gods movie that
they're making based on the Tom King run
they haven't said anything about
earth-based characters or Justice League
characters appearing in it
maybe but too soon to tell it sounds
like most of the movie is going to be set
in outer space and it's mostly about mr.
miracle and big Barda trying to protect
their family or their relationship from
Darkseid and apocalypse but the movies
just inspired by the comic book they're
not doing the exact same comic-book plot
it'll be a lot of Jack Kirby deep cuts
for the original fourth world comics and
I've already done a video about what's
going on with another Man of Steel
Superman movie for those wondering where
a Man of Steel 2 is right now they're
not making it because the studio doesn't
think it can make enough money on one
right now so in order to give Henry
Cavill a chance to prove himself because
they don't want to get rid of him yet or
anything like that they're doing the
multi-picture crossover deal and after
those crossovers happened they'll
reassess the situation and either pull
the trigger on another Superman movie
or just recast the character and reboot
the franchise like they're doing with
the Matt Reeves Batman movies so if you
want Henry Cavill to get another
Superman's solo movie the best thing you
can do one is obviously tell the studio
that you want another Superman movie but
also support the movies that Henry
Cavill appears in in the future so if
he's going to be in Shazam 2 in the Black
Adam movie you have to go see those
movies and support that so that the
studio realizes that people are excited
to see Henry Cavill Superman appear in
movies when it comes to lobbying the
studio to get something that you want
from them the best thing you can do is
just vote with your money because that's
the main thing that the studio wants
they want your money Warner Brothers
also just made an animated man of
tomorrow Superman movie I just did a
trailer video for it yesterday you can
click here to watch that it's a
completely new voice cast and you can
click here for my new Justice League
Snyder cut trailer video in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!